un écureuil ici on a fait là on avait
deux enfants
on attendait oui et supervise y est
incroyable c'est moche qu'on dit c'est
que quand on perd pas contre voir enfin
ce pas peur personne est venu pour voir
s'ils savourent pas
rien ap
l'homme non identifié
comment c'est
je vais me dit avant terme en attendant
quelque chose de ligue 1 auxerre
ok
à cet effet elle a donc un double pas
que l'etranger
ok ok vous connaissez pourquoi c'est
beau et passionnant pour les faits sont
là le check check point
merci ok heureusement peu secouer un peu
plus au kawkab le hockey
dans le bordel là dedans c'est un vrai
bordel de jei camions de vieux trucs se
passe tu vois un peu mais plus de
vendanger bien des dents devant la mer
demain normalement hier pour un peu
peut-être un peu moins serré dans cette
passionnante épopée siens bon c'est pas
extraordinaire
il ne fait déjà mais c'est tout ça que
d'écarter un peu plus de doigté quartier
en allant vers le haut car l'eau en
écartant vers le haut votre silence et
qui ça bordel de des ligatures du
lieutenant posté un message de voiture
alors ses autres usines d'aluminium va
s'en aller
l'avenant passer pour un art de la lame
avant vers la base navale et tu vas
descendre un peu maladroite et sans la
route de la droite arad la lave et bien
la route en haut up se réécoute est le
match
casey's au froid à la tête qu'on ne doit
pas ce que c'est que de la matière pour
faire un petit peu tard dans le lagon
baiser hockey dehors la vague bleue des
vêtements envers l'ex gloire et gedo
l'oeil